Nancy Pelosi is hailed as a genius while
pursuing an idiotic impeachment gambit
members of the media blamed Trump for
Iran accidentally shooting down a
civilian airliner and congressional
Democrats suddenly objects to executive
war-making power i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressive VPN protect your online
privacy today and expressvpn comm slash
ban okay so we have now reached the
point where impeachment might at some
point be given to the Senate I mean I
can't say that it's actually gonna
happen that you know the impeachment
charges will be handed by Nancy Pelosi
to the Senate because she's still
playing this idiotic game or she's like
maybe I'll hand it to them but maybe I
won't but maybe I will but maybe I won't
make up your mind lady which is it even
members of Nancy Pelosi's own party are
starting to look at her like is their
strategy to any of this or are you just
kind of winging it like what was this
here's the problem for Nancy Pelosi
originally when she launched this
impeachment effort she figured that it
was a low-risk high-reward gambit that
basically no matter what happened she
was gonna be on good terms with her own
base because something super damaging
would come out about from something
damaging enough they would really hurt
him for 20/20 so even if they impeached
in the house and he was acquitted in the
Senate it would hurt Trump going forward
there's only one problem
Trump's poll numbers have been
absolutely stable everything in the
world is baked into this cake when it
comes to trump everything eggshells baby
poop custard like everything is in the
cake okay and everybody knows that it's
in the cake so Nancy Pelosi thought well
probably they would take something up it
turns out they didn't dig up anything
that was supremely to the point of
impeachment damning they dug up some
stuff that probably could have gotten
him censured in the house maybe even
censured in the Senate but nothing that
merited impeachment and so now Nancy
Pelosi is stuck with this conundrum if
she submits these articles impeachment
to the Senate and the Senate just
dismisses them immediately then this
thing is over and she was a giant
failure because she has declared herself
a very important person for having
pursued this nonsense if however she
holds this thing back and doesn't submit
it to the Senate then I guess in her own
mind she looks stubborn I guess in her
own mind she looks like she's trying to
play brinksmanship with Mitch McConnell
but she doesn't have any leverage the
whole thing is idiotic so here was Nancy
Pelosi yesterday explaining that she was
actually saving the country with this
impeachment of she's been busy she's
been too busy to go to San Francisco
49ers games by the way not too busy to
go to fundraisers not too busy to mouth
off about how her home city of San
Francisco is being run beautifully
despite feces and needles on the street
but she's saving the country as Nancy
Pelosi so here's Nancy Pelosi explaining
yesterday that her gambit of not
impeachment charges to the Senate is
somehow saving America my Democratic
very net hat
political leader this weekend so his
responsibilities to save the country
this weekend oh the superhero and the
same members of the media who term Ruth
Bader Ginsburg the notorious RBG
suggests that Nancy Pelosi is somehow
saving the country this idiotic yam but
we'll get to more of Nancy Pelosi in
just one second but first let's talk
about a simple fact if you look at every
single study that's ever been done the
fact is if you look better if you look
like you are doing your hair in the
morning if you look like you're doing
your makeup if you are a lady if you
look like your teeth are straight all of
this can help you in life and in
business looking better is a very
important thing in life I know sounds
superficial but it's just the reality
well if you understand that your teeth
have slipped out of place ever since you
had braces when you are a teenager you
need to be using candid why
well candid delivers clear aligners
directly to you and straightens your
teeth for 65 percent less than braces
unlike braces kensic clear aligners are
comfortable removable totally invisible
so you can transform your smile without
anyone noticing a thing plus you never
have to set foot in a doctor's office or
waiting room your treatment is
prescribed remotely by a licensed
orthodontist Kenda delivers everything
you need directly to your door which is
a lot better than having to go to the
orthodontist office and sit in the
office and wait around have an
appointment
instead you can do it all from your home
I did the entire early process from my
house they make it super easy to give
you a step-by-step guide unlike other
companies hands it only works with
orthodontist they don't just work with
general dentists which means that your
treatment will be designed by an expert
in tooth with 20 years of experience on
average so are you ready to take the
first step towards straighter teeth for
a limited time you can get started with
75 bucks off by using coach Shapiro at
candid co.com slash Shapiro that's
candid co.com slash Shapiro use coach
apparel for 75 bucks off candid co.com
Shapiro code Shapiro
and in co.com slash apparel use that
coach Shapiro for 75 bucks off okay so
Nancy Pelosi says that she will at some
point send the impeachment charges over
but not right now because like right now
is bad because it's just bad guys and
and when asked about her strategies like
I have a strategy it's in my head it's
the most brilliant strategy ever heard
I'm doing the Trump voice cuz actually
that must be what's playing there except
sounds like trouble here's Nancy Pelosi
doing her routine I'll send them over
when I'm ready
probably I don't you know you said if
you don't send him over I'm gonna pass
in Mexico US Canada Trade Agreement okay
we want to see what they're willing to
do okay and you can see her with her
hands she's fumbling with things on the
podium like she knows she knows that she
has put herself in this idiotic
strategic box and so the only tool that
she has left his clubbing her Democratic
colleagues into submission so yesterday
there's a democratic representative who
made the crucial errors name was Adam
Smith of suggesting on live television
that the Speaker of the House should
move along the charges and then within
hours he was walking that thing back
because Nancy Pelosi called him up and
said you can't do that so he wrote a
tweet he said I misspoke this morning I
do believe we should do everything we
can to force the Senate to have a fair
trial if the speaker believes that
holding on to the articles for a longer
time will help force a fair trial in the
Senate then I wholeheartedly support
that decision I am concerned that
Senator McConnell won't have a fair
trial
I'm with the speaker that we should do
everything we can to ensure he does
ultimately says representative Adam
Smith I do want the article sent to the
Senate for the very simple reason that I
want the impeachment process to go
forward so reiterating his original
position but bending over backwards in
order to please Nancy Pelosi
I mean all of this is a mess it's a mess
CNN's Don Lemon even was puzzled last
night saying I'm confused so if she
hands over the charges is she caving if
she doesn't hand over the charges is she
somehow doing something strongly what is
going on here
leader McConnell he's not giving in to
Nancy Pelosi's demand so if she sends
the articles without knowing what's
happening in the trial isn't he getting
exactly what he wants for now it sure
seems like that and I think if you were
making a prediction you would say this
is going to be an impeachment trial
probably without witnesses okay so again
the this puts
Pelosi in a position where she is now
sap a standard for herself she can't me
because if she doesn't submit the
impeachment charges then McConnell just
moves on with his day and if she does
submit the impeachment charges then
McConnell moves on with his day so she
has no leverage whatsoever Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell signed
on to Senator Josh Haley's resolution
yesterday to change the Senate rules
which would allow the Senate to vote to
dismiss the Democrats articles of
impeachment if Nancy Pelosi has not
submitted the articles of impeachment
within the next 25 days according to
Ryan's Vedra over at Daily wire New York
Times reported Nicholas fanzone reported
on Thursday that McConnell had signed on
to the resolution as a co-sponsor to
change the Senate impeachment rules to
allow the chamber to dismiss the houses
articles if they are not sent over
within 25 days no one of the reasons
that's important is because there's been
a lot of speculation could Nancy Pelosi
just hold the impeachment charges for
like three years until Democrats
eventually gain control of the Senate
and then they impeach Trump if he's
reluctant could they just do that like
let's say the Democrats lose their house
but gain the Senate could they actually
act on old impeachment charges they're
all these kind of weird vagaries in
American law this way right now there's
a big debate that's about to happen over
the Equal Rights Amendment yes you heard
that right the Equal Rights Amendment
which did not pass back in the late
1970s well now Democrats have tried to
revive in a few states the Equal Rights
Amendment and then suggested that they
have the supermajority of states
approving the Equal Rights Amendment
there's only one problem it's been a
40-year delay and the original Equal
Rights Amendment proposal by the United
States Senate contained within it an
expiration date but this is something
the Democrats actually have done in the
past they've tried to bring up old
legislation and then pass it as though
it were new so McConnell is saying about
impeachment here we'll just dismiss it
okay if you're not going to do this
we'll dismiss it we'll take up your bill
as though you had submitted it to us and
then we'll just dismiss it and we'll
change the Senate rules in order to do
so McConnell slammed Pelosi for spending
part weeks undermining the institution
of the presidency with a historically
unfair and subjective impeachment and
now for the sequel they've come after
the institution of the Senate as well
when you step back from the political
noise and the pundits discussing
leverage that never existed whathave
House Democrats actually done he said
this is what they've actually done they
initiated one of the most grave and
unsettling processes in our Constitution
and then refused to allow a resolution
the speaker began something she herself
predicted would be so divisive to the
country and now she's unilaterally
saying it cannot move forward toward
resolution which of course is true now
this is not going to stop the media from
proclaiming Nancy Pelosi a full-scale
Thomas Edison Albert Einstein
style genius Time magazine has a cover
story with a glowing picture of Nancy
Pelosi I mean so beautiful it the
picture online is a picture of her
backlit a little bit so you get the halo
around her head it's just gorgeous
and it's called weave up to the ante my
Nancy Pelosi is going all-in against
Trump Molly ball writing and the entire
piece is just this boring annoying
pandering to Nancy Pelosi everything
that she does is brilliant and wonderful
everything she does is draped ingenious
according to Molly ball Pelosi has spent
decades at the highest levels of
politics but the past 12 months have
arguably arguably been her most
consequential returning to the
speakership after eight years running
the House Democratic minority she
established herself as a counterweight
and constrain ur of this divisive
president yeah she's a Democrat like now
that's called being a Democrat she
outmaneuvered Trump on policy from the
border wall he didn't get to the budget
agreement he signed loaded with goodies
the Democrats want she oversaw an
unprecedented litigation effort against
the executive branch racking up landmark
court victories which by the way were
mostly overturned by the Supreme Court
and she was the tactician behind the
investigation that resulted in Trump's
impeachment on December 18th
wow the tactician can you imagine the
tactical genius that it requires in
order for you to get your own caucus to
vote to impeach presidents of the
opposite party I mean it must just be
tactical genius I mean this person she's
like she's like the George Patton of
politics and it's just amazing jake
robert e lee during his great forays
into northern virginia like what are you
talking about this is just nonsense you
know it's just pure nonsense but again
the media will always portray democrats
as brilliant at worst democrats are
misunderstood they're never just dumb
they never just a dumb thing instead
it's no democrats are geniuses and you
don't all understand their genius that's
the big problem you don't all understand
their genius so is this impeachment
effort going anywhere the answer of
course is no Nancy Pelosi understands
it's going nowhere which is why she's
not pushing this to the Senate because
the moments it's taken up by the Senate
we are one week away from this whole
thing being over and then the attention
turns back to the Democrats and the fact
that they have a bunch of garbage
candidates running for president and the
economy is strong and president Trump
has taken out the two top terrorists on
planet earth in the last four months
okay they don't want that they want the
impeachment in the news but they don't
want it in the news so much that people
actually look at the fact that Nancy
Pelosi and the Democrats do not have a
proper case and just once
we're going to get it and we're going to
get to the latest Democrat and media
spin about President Trump and Soleimani
because of course everything that Trump
does no matter how good must be
portrayed as bad and evil will get to
all of that in just one second first
let's talk about the fact that maybe you
just moved maybe you're just looking
around that new apartment maybe looking
around that new house and you're
thinking yourself I need to upgrade this
place or maybe even living in your place
for a while but you haven't really
thought about upgrading the place in a
while you know one thing that people
tend to overlook when you move into a
place or when you've been living there
for a while is the window coverings I
realized this maybe a year ago when I
was looking around my house and I was
like I've been here for a few years and
there's still something dingy about it
and I realized that the window coverings
on the back windows were the same as
they were when I moved in they're
probably the same as they were like
three owners ago well it was time to
replace all those and so I went over to
blinds.com and you should to blinds.com
makes it really easy for you if you're
not sure what you want or even where to
start with blinds calm you get a free
online design consultation you just send
them pictures of your house and they
send back custom recommendations from a
professional for what will work with
your color scheme furniture and specific
rooms they will even send you free
samples to make sure that everything
looks as good in person as it does
online and that every order gets free
shipping and here's the best part
if you accidentally miss measure or you
pick the wrong color if you make a
mistake blinds.com will remake your
blinds at for free so I mean you're the
screw-up then matter blinds comm will
make the magic happen for you for a
limited time get 20% off everything at
blinds comm when you use promo code Ben
that is blinds.com promo code Ben for
20% off everything that's the faux wood
blinds the cellular shades the roller
shades and more blinds.com promo code
Ben rules and restrictions do apply
blinds.com promo code Ben okay so in the
effort to turn the Soleimani killing
which ended with the iranians backing
down into a loss for president trump the
democrats in the media will seize on
literally anything in the most
disgusting despicable fashion i mean
this really is disgusting and despicable
so yesterday it turned out that the the
there was a ukrainian jetliner that
crashed near tehran on tuesday right in
the middle of this these missile attacks
that were being made by the iranian
government on iraqi air bases and it was
the american government has now declared
that it was likely that these were shot
down by ron it's pretty obvious from the
from the fuselage that it was shot down
by iran there was no actual emergency
call the black box will not be turned
over by
on to Boeing this is Boeing jet so it
was not mechanical failure Chiron almost
certainly did this Canadian Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau whose country
lost at least 63 citizens in the downing
set in Ottawa we have intelligence from
multiple sources including our allies
and our own intelligence the evidence
indicates that the plane was shot down
by an Iranian surface-to-air missile
likewise UK Prime Minister Boris Johnson
and Australian prime minister Scott
Morrison offered similar statements
Morrison also said it appeared to be a
mistake all of the intelligence has
presented to us today does not suggest
an intentional act which of course makes
perfect sense why would you shoot down a
plane originating from your own
territory
this was somebody got trigger-happy on
the Iranian side while they were firing
missiles and they thought maybe that
there was some something coming the
other way and they decided that they
were gonna shoot down a civilian
airliner so it was likely a mistake it
shows how horribly run the Iranian
administration is this was not caught in
the crossfire there was no crossfire and
this was just the Iranians sucking at
their jobs and the deaths of a hundred
and eighty people resulting therefrom
again this thing took off from Tehran's
Airport it was in the air from less than
two minutes and then it was shot down so
that's Iran's fault right that's Iran
being a horrible dictatorship that was
in the middle of firing missiles into a
foreign country and decided what if
somebody got trigger-happy and shot down
a civilian airliner so that was the
story the media tried to blame Trump for
this somehow it's Trump's fault that
Iran accidentally shot down a civilian
airliner in its own airspace originating
from its own Airport somehow this is
president Trump's fall doesn't matter
that the United States had issued a
no-fly order over Iran and Iraq hours
before the Ukrainian plane was down the
FAA had stopped US commercial traffic
over the region understanding that Iran
was likely to do something bad the
no-fly orders were published roughly
three hours before the accident
according to an FAA spokesperson the
no-fly order outlined flight
restrictions that prohibited u.s. civil
aviation operators from operating in the
airspace over Iraq Iran and the waters
of the Persian Gulf and the Gulf of Oman
doesn't matter the media many in the
media and the Democrats tried to blame
Trump for this so in other words the
Iranians would never have shot down an
airliner accidentally over their own
airspace exit they didn't on purpose
they didn't do it in retaliation for the
United States doing a thing they
accidentally shot down their own
airliner because they're incompetent
because they're evil and those two
things are combined okay because it was
not
evil right they didn't purposely shoot
down the airliner but they're evil in
attempting to retaliate for the killing
of their terror leader led to them
accidentally shooting down a civilian
airliner and murdering a bunch of
civilians members of the left are trying
to blame President Trump for this the
headline at huffington post today is
collateral damage scores of civilians
collateral damage the united states
didn't do anything here the united
states didn't blow up the civilian
airliner the united states wasn't even
firing anything into iran this happened
over iranian airspace not even over
Iraqi airspace but according to The
Huffington Post the downed plane which
is solely the fault of the Iranians is
apparently Trump's fault The Associated
Press did the same thing The Associated
Press tweeted out this is insane
sickening imagine having a family member
on that plane what began with a drone
attack on a top Iranian general
rippled outward until dozens of Iranian
Canadians and dozens of Iranian students
studying in Canada were dead so in other
words if Trump had never hit Soleimani
then the airliner never gets down
alternatively if Iran wants a garbage
terror regime that was intent on
spreading terror across the region none
of this would have been a problem
because guess where civilian airliners
aren't getting down by members of their
own government any Western country yeah
that's not a thing and in times when the
United States has accidentally down an
airliner like back in the 1980s there
was actual crossfire there's actual
crossfire happening this is much more
reminiscent of the Russian government
the Russian government purposely shot
down a Malaysian airliner probably this
one was accidental because it was it
doesn't benefit Iran in any way they
obviously didn't want to do it it wasn't
like Iran was like you know what we got
to do something to hurt those Americans
we're shooting down our own airliner
that's what we're doing today that's not
what happened but the attempt to blame
Trump for this is full-scale crazy towns
I mean it's nuts Pete Budaj edge being
Pete Buddha judge these are the every
softening mask mask he sort of
masquerades as a moderate but that ain't
who people judges on the inside P Buddha
judge tweeted out innocent civilians are
now dead because they were caught in the
middle of an unnecessary and unwanted
military tit-for-tat cut in the middle
the United States didn't fire any
ordnance into Iran we took out a
terrorist bad guy in Iraq Iran shoots
down an airliner of its own airspace
originating from Iranian from Iranian
airports and that's the United States is
fault that is
Italy like saying that somebody comes
and robs your house and you call the
police the police arrive at that other
person's house and when the police
arrive the person inside the house and
attempt to shoot the police shoots their
own wife is that your fault or is that
the fault of the person who shot their
wife accidentally like this is this is
ridiculous
then Buddha judge says my thoughts are
with the families and loved ones of all
176 souls lost aboard this flight if
your thoughts were with then then maybe
you should think about the fact that the
regime that shot them down is the regime
that is to blame for all of this it
wasn't just Buddha judge either this
became like this has become the talking
point on the left because Trump won a
victory against Iran because Iran back
down because their terror leader is dead
they have to find something they can pin
on Trump they're trying to pin World War
3 on Trump that was never going to
materialize because the Iranians more
than anybody else the ayatollahs did not
want to go to full-scale war with
President Trump he had just vaporized
their terror leader the ayatollahs did
not want to end up in the same number of
pieces that Soleimani ended up so Trump
gets the win they won't give him the win
instead Iran doing a bad thing to people
originating from its own country from an
init own airspace now that's from smog
so I suppose that if Iran starts
shooting dissenters in the street that's
also Trump's fault because Trump is
opposing Iran too strongly like well
what is the even the logic here how is
this logic even follow Abel it doesn't
matter people have to find something to
blame front for here and turn a win into
a loss there's another report from The
Wall Street Journal today doing the same
thing there's a report from The Wall
Street Journal by the way people should
note the Wall Street Journal editorial
page is conservative The Wall Street
Journal news page is actually more
liberal than the New York Times there
been studies that have shown this okay
so the Wall Street Journal The Wall
Street Journal reports today that Trump
was saying to people that he hit
soleimani in order to get wavering
senators on his side for impeachment
what wavering senators there's literally
no evidence that a single Republican
senator was ready to vote for
impeachment so this is just pure fantasy
it's just pure nonsense
doesn't matter everything Trump does has
to be turned into an L it doesn't matter
if it's a big W it has to be turned into
an L by the media and by the Democrats
and so they'll come up with this strange
logic or Ron shoots down and err again
it was an it was an Iranian originating
flight in Iranian airspace two minutes
after takeoff and it was accidental
the Iranians who didn't want to do this
Ben Rhodes that that piece of dreck
Rhodes tweets out whenever there's a war
there are unintended consequences oh
yeah tell it's your boss after the
Libyan debacle I mean it's it's it's
just I'm sorry this is all ridiculous
it's ridiculous and it's purely
politically driven okay we'll get to
more of this in just one second first
let's talk about what you do if you have
you know an employee who really is on
that board on let's say that there's an
employee at your company
let's just call her Nika for example and
let's say she's really just have to like
she's really delightful but she does the
makeup on your show and every so often
well you are in the middle of reading
your phone just before the show you know
checking the news doing what's really
important she sort of sprays you in the
face with with makeup just randomly boom
right in the grille and let's say you
think you know I don't really want that
today instead I need to go to zip
recruiter because zipper crews we're
gonna get the best possible candidate
zip recruiter sends your job to over 100
of the web's leading job boards but they
don't stop there with their powerful
matching technology zip recruiter scans
thousands of resumes to find people with
the right experience and then invites
them to apply to your job as
applications come in zip recruiter
analyzes each one and spotlights the top
candidates so you're never going to miss
a great match the zipper career is so
effective that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter a no
quality candidate through the site
within the very first day it's really
important to get hiring right so that
you don't have someone like let's say
Nika who just sort of mixes up your
wardrobe with the Wardrobe of the other
host and suddenly you're trying on
shirts that are too small for you really
right now my listeners can try super
cooter for free at this exclusive web
address zip recruiter dot-com slash
daily wire that is zip recruiter comm
slash Dai ly WI re zip recruiter comm
slash daily wire zipper queries indeed
the smartest way to hire upgrade your
business get the best people zip
recruiter dot-com slash daily wire so as
I say the attempt to turn this win for
Trump into a loss is pretty astonishing
I had on Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
on the radio show this is why I should
subscribe over it daily where I come I
had Secretary of State Pompeo on the
show yesterday and rightly he's
bewildered by the media coverage of this
because the media coverage of this is
just egregious and so is the Democratic
response
representative Jackie Speier of
California who really I mean has the
intelligence of a potato she was on with
Wolf Blitzer explaining that it was
trump's fault that iran shot down a
passenger plane again originating from
its own airport in its own airspace if
what is being projected
is true this is yet another example of
collateral damage from the actions that
have been taken in a provocative way by
the president United States okay so it's
the United States is komal II when you
say collateral damage what you mean is
that the United States did an airstrike
on a terror target and there were
civilians nearby and those civilians
were hurt or killed that's what
collateral damage is it's where we do
something that ends with civilian
casualties but we were actually not
aiming at those people we were aiming at
the bad guys what relationship does that
have to a raunch shooting down a
civilian airliner in its own airspace
what relationship
no crossfire by the way again no
confusion here at the United States did
not launch a single piece of ordnance
that night not one and yet the media are
covering this as though this is Trump's
fault because they got to find something
to blame front for even if it's just the
Iranian government being a garbage
terror regime Saira Rao who once ran for
Congress as a Democrat she's the author
of some books that nobody cares about
she tweeted out every single one of the
176 passengers on the Ukrainian plane
then went down was murdered by Donald
Trump murdered by Donald Trump weird
because it seems like the piece of
anti-aircraft ordnance that went through
the plane had Iranian markings on it
happened on Iranian territory in Iranian
airspace and there was nothing coming
from the United States at all she says
we have to start calling a thing a thing
and stop pretending this man in America
are not the biggest terrorists in the
world America is the biggest terrorist
in the world America okay you want a
one-way ticket to Iran I mean I wouldn't
take it because it doesn't seem like
they treat their airliners all that well
but there is a cadre of Americans who
really really blame America first for
nearly everything and it's disgusting
it's disgusting
okay Barack Obama's policy was truly
awful it was truly awful and it lacked
and you could point to his policy as the
rationale for strengthening bad guys
around the world but when a terrorist
commits a terror act is that Barack
Obama's specific fault when the Orlando
Pulse nightclub shooting happened under
Obama's administration that was not
Obama's fault I mean that was it that
was the fault of the terrorists yeah and
that's especially not Obama's fault if
he were fighting Isis harder they claim
that Trump was too harsh on Iran so Iran
shot down accidentally its own airliner
so this is Trump's fault
it's just patently insane it's patently
insane but again the Democrats will do
anything in order to blame Trump for
what is
obviously a win and suggest that
everything was hunky-dory until this
very moment and then everything that
goes wrong from the points at which
Trump does a thing that's all on Trump
it's amazing
the Democrats tend to read current
events the same way they read history so
Democrats members of the media what they
do when they look at American history
for example is they point to all of the
bad things that have happened in
American history and yes there are
plenty of them the mistreatment of
Native Americans the the hunter the
centuries-long issue of slavery the
century of Jim Crow they point to all
the bad things in American history and
then they say because America is
uniquely bad and they never ever take a
broader view and say okay well it's true
America did all of these terrible
horrible no good very bad things but
most of human history is replete with
all of these terrible horrible very good
very bad no-good things all over the
globe the question is why did America do
things right not why did America do
things wrong why did America do things
right so it's always thrown into for
Democrats for the media it's always that
everything can be blamed on America
because they hone in on everything
America is wrong they never ever
contrast what America does right with
the rest of the world so it becomes
America's fault whenever anything goes
wrong that's a very convenient way of
looking at the world if you wish to
suggest that America needs to withdraw
that America power America's power in
the world needs to be minimized that
America's history is egregious and bad
all the way through that myopic view is
ugly and wrong and stupid but it is
pursued by a huge number of people these
days including former Secretary of State
John Kerry who has to insist that the
world began spinning when Donald Trump
became president until Trump became
president everything was sort of Russo
II in paradise it was he need any place
the world and then Donald Trump came
along and then things started to go bad
now this happens to be a complete lie
but that's what John Kerry is best at
the worst Secretary of State in American
history John Kerry also an awful senator
also a liar about his fellow troops in
Vietnam John Kerry he has a piece in The
New York Times today called diplomacy
was working until Trump abandoned it
really was it what was it working
because I seem to remember a vast
outbreak of Iranian terrorism all across
the region plus additional developments
of ballistic missile technology under
the Iran nuclear deal that you promoted
and lie to the American people about but
John Kerry says presidents from foes but
on his watch Ron will never be allowed
to have a nuclear weapon but if he had
wanted to keep that promise he should
have left the 2015 Iran nuclear
agreement in place instead he pulled the
United States out of the deal that deal
at best at best hadn't run voluntarily
agreeing not to develop further its
nuclear program until like 2023 2025
somewhere in that period that was it
that's all the deal did and then turn
the spigots right back on from those
nuclear weapons and they could be part
of the world economy while doing it and
have expanded their terrorist regional
power the Iran nuclear deal was not even
a band-aid it was a misdirection from
the key problem which is that the
Iranian regime is cancerous but
according John Kerry it's all about
Trump he says after mr. Trump authorized
the KO'ing of Major General call seemed
soleimani last week Iran announced it
was no longer obligated to follow the
agreement now mr. Trump has since walked
back from the brink of war I can't
explain the chaos of his presidency as
it lurches from crisis to crisis real or
manufactured the president has said he
doesn't to access strategies clearly he
doesn't to strategies mihrab John Carr
look okay let's just point out that the
Obama administration's strategy was sign
checks to these people was to give money
to soleimani that was their actual
strategy but according to John Kerry
everything bad that has happened is the
fault of of Trump and that this is
amazing here's John Kerry let's get one
straw mountain out of the wire general
Soleimani was they sworn unapologetic
enemy of the United States a kg Field
Marshal who oversaw Iran's long strategy
to extend the country's influence
through sectarian proxies in the region
he won't be mourned or missed by anyone
in the West
occasionally when American and Iranian
interests align we were certain to bid
as beneficiaries of his relationships
but this was a rare exception this
underscores the tragic irony of mr.
Trump's decision to abrogate the nuclear
agreement it played into general sway
Moniz hardline strategy by weakening
voices for diplomacy within the tower on
which he's just gonna keep going with
this line this was the lie promoted by
the by the Obama administration that
there were hardliners and moderates and
Obama had empowered the moderates really
I'm need you to show me the moderates
point to him is it Hassan rouhani really
is it Hassan Rowhani was it was a
continued job like who are the moderates
inside Iran in the Iranian government
the moderates I see are the ones getting
shot in the streets by the Iranian
regime propped up by the money the John
Kerry and Barack Obama handed to them
it's oh just a disastrous attempt to
backfill Obama's crap foreign policy
that's all this is okay meanwhile the
House voted on a resolution to curtail
Trump's War Powers yesterday is a
non-binding measure so it means
absolutely nothing according to Politico
the House voted on Thursday to halt
further US military action against Iran
in a powerful rebuke of Donald Trump's
use of force overseas without
congressional approval really was it a
powerful rebuke or was it a bunch of
Democrats with virtually no Republican
support saying that they don't like
Trump is that is that what that is
because I'm missing the powerful and I'm
missing the rebuke and also I'm missing
how this means anything the answer is of
course it doesn't Democrats are just mad
that Trump got a W here and so of course
they're trying to turn it into an L with
the help of the media well get some more
of this in just one second because the
behavior of the Democrats on the score
has been utterly ridiculous utterly
ridiculous we got some more of it in a
second first it is that glorious time of
the week when I give a shout-out to a
daily wire subscriber next week it could
be you today it's Alisa Elbert on
Twitter who knows good news when she
sees it in this picture
lissa is holding the glorious
incomparable leftist ears tumbler into
frame next to her adorable puppy look at
that doggy good doggy in response to a
tweet of the Ayatollah weeping at
terrorists general Soleimani funeral
ELISA writes this calls for my leftist
ears tumblr yes indeed he was a bad bad
evil very bad man
Trump was right to take him out the
world is better off in his absence
thanks for the picture and thanks for
your support you could be featured next
week if you're not already a subscriber
you're really missing out head on over
to daily wire.com slash subscribe for as
little as 10 bucks a month you get our
articles had free access to all of our
live broadcasts our full show library
select bonus content and our exclusive
daily wire app which is pretty fantastic
feature if you haven't checked it out
yet if you choose the new All Access
plan you'll get all of that plus the
legendary leftist ears tumblr and our
brand-new ask me anything a style
discussion feature though allows you to
engage our hosts writers special guests
on a weekly basis so stop depriving
yourself and come join the fun you are
listening to the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
so political reports mostly party line
vote on a symbolic non-binding
resolution came days after Trump ordered
the killing of top Iranian general Qasem
Soleimani
now you want to hear how hypocritical
and ridiculous the Democrats are on this
point I'm just gonna play you a couple
of clips of Nancy Pelosi so yesterday
Nancy Pelosi said that this was an
assassination and an assault on Iran it
was an assault on Iran to kill the
terror leader who's been spreading
terror like literal death against
American troops for years who's been
spreading terror across the region his
killing was an assassination which means
it was in violation of American law the
word assassination has actual legal
ramifications because there are
executive orders in place to prevent
assassination of foreign officials and
she says it was an assault on Iran so
Trump is the bad guy here's Nancy Pelosi
saying we have to curtail Trump's War
Powers because Trump is the bad guy
despite the fact that Iran has been
consistently pursuing terrorism across
the region from administration to
administration without cease the United
States had a high-level may be the
second most important person in the
country assassinated wherever the United
States might consider that assault on
our country right and the Iranians might
as well even though this took place at
the Iraqi airport and so it's it's foggy
there are those who think well it was
dinner wrong so it counts but it was in
the salt on Iran so it shouldn't count
she's literally defending the Iranian
regime now from their perspective I mean
she is defending the Iranian regime
that's not defending Soleimani as a
human but she's defending the Iranian
regime she's saying that America was the
aggressor in killing an Iranian
terrorist on Iraqi territory it's
unbelievable and on that basis she says
we need a War Powers Resolution to
restrain power now as I said yesterday
if you're Senator Mike Lee and it is
your stick and it is that the
Constitution grants war-making power to
Congress and you have across
administration's wanted that power
brought back to Congress I get it
Mike Lee is consistent I may disagree
with his application of the rules but
he's a consistent person Nancy Pelosi
and the Democrats are just full of crap
here's Nancy Pelosi flashback like a
couple of years saying that Barack Obama
not only did not need authorization to
kill terrorists he did not need
congressional authorization to enter a
scale air war in Libya you forget about
killing a terrorist which is fully legal
hit Barack Obama did not need
congressional authorization to conduct a
full-scale war in Libya this is a Nancy
Pelosi like five minutes ago
they are so full of bleep it's unreal
super figure flattering leader you're
saying that the President did not need
authorization initially and still does
not need any authorization from Congress
one Libya yes yes just straight up yes
no authorization this was this by the
way was weeks after the invasion of
Libya it's it so are we supposed to take
this complaint by Elisabetta non-si
Pelosi seriously super seriously she
cares about that constitutional limits
and the prerogatives of Congress sure
sure she does and this is the Democratic
message the Democratic message is they
are doing PR for the Iranian regime
which of course is not a surprise
because the Obama administration
routinely did PR for the Iranian regime
that in fact was part of the bargain the
Iran nuclear deal was predicated on the
Obama administration lines the American
people that now all problems with Iran
were solved up soon including when they
put American sailors on their knees
force them to hold their hands behind
their head as they took an American ship
hostage okay the fact is that Iranian
terrorism around the region never ceased
and I'm sick to death of this notion
that everything began when Trump became
president or when Trump did X Y or Z
read a dams book you idiots then you
have I mean they're really doing it's
amazing they're doing full-on they
should be paid honestly if you're gonna
do this at least take the money
Elizabeth Warren yesterday who had to be
bullied into admitting that soleimani
was a terrorist by Meghan McCain because
nobody in the media will ask her a
straight question because she's she's
Elizabeth Warren she's got a plan for
that and she's the worst answer in human
history she was doing an interview with
that
unbelievable journalistic outlet
Cosmopolitan magazine so cosmopolitan
magazine's cover was like Elizabeth
Warren speaks about Iran and also nine
new sex positions that'll blow his mind
here was Elizabeth Warren last night
explaining that Soleimani was a bad guy
but he was a high-ranking Iranian
official and therefore we probably
shouldn't have done this it's not that
he was a bad guy he said he was a
terrorist this is a legal standard he'd
been labeled a terrorist by the American
government he was
a car with another terrorist but she
won't say that unless megan mccain is
there basically
browbeating her here's Elizabeth Warren
getting away with her yeah he was a mean
like how bad was he Nancy I mean I mean
Elizabeth how bad was he was he like bad
as in like The Bachelor like a mean guy
on The Bachelor or was he bad as in like
murdering hundreds of American troops
here's a Lizabeth morons downplaying how
bad soleimani was in order Clement he
was just sort of a normal bad
antagonistic official no Vladimir Putin
is a bad guy who's a foreign official
this guy was pursuing a terror building
across the entire region the principal
job of the President of the United
States is to keep America safe and
ordering the killing of Soleimani
who was a bad guy but a high-ranking
Iranian government official has not made
America safer he was a bad guy again but
he was but he was a high-ranking
government official who was the leader
of their terrorist operation now that
there's still a few sane Democrats out
there Democrat max Rose from New York
for example and he says listen I don't
think that we need to limit presidential
war powers here just because the
President of the United States killed
the terrorists like that's absurd when
it comes to congressional power much of
this power is found in appropriations if
Congress disagrees with a protracted and
extensive war and that's not what we see
today with Iran well it has the power of
the purse and that's where Congress
should exert itself we should not be
passing resolutions like we just did
today
which sends the message the American
people that were on the brink of war I
don't believe that we are Qasem
Soleimani
was a terrorist who should have been
killed and no one should mourn his loss
good for max Rosen how about that guy in
the Democratic primaries huh max Rosen
about like a reasonable human being in
the Democratic primaries no we can't do
that even Jay Johnson the Homeland
Security Secretary on Barack Obama
Barack Obama who used to do a drone war
killing terrorists routinely jeh Johnson
was like yeah of course it's legal for
Trump to kill Soleimani what is this
nonsense where it's illegal or it's an
assassination or it's an act of war
effort from Tequila terrorists under
existing office of legal counsel
opinions on the president's
constitutional authority to engage the
Armed Forces without a congressional
authorization if you read those opinions
he had ample constitutional authority to
take out general Soleimani if you regard
that as an isolated strike what these
OLC opinion say is that the president
can take lethal force so long as it's
short of war if it's in the important
national interest and then this and this
operation was even jeh Johnson who's an
Obama guy is like yeah no this is not
pretty pretty fine pretty fine it's only
the people who are defending Obama's
overall strategy who have a problem with
this including all of the idiots in the
media Chris Cuomo a living human log was
on CNN last night explaining that every
single person if they were a patriot
should have voted for the War Powers
Resolution I remember him being super
exercised about the war in Libya I
remember him being super exercised about
Obama's drone war I remember I remember
him saying you know what we need we need
a rebalancing of legislative and
executive power again I'm fine with the
principle of rebalancing legislative and
executive power although I think would
be very difficult to draw a standard
under any circumstances under which the
Constitution of the United States does
not give the commander-in-chief the
ability to make a quick strike against a
terrorist I think George Washington
would have done it okay but Chris Cuomo
trying to suggest that he's just a
constitutionalist why won't anyone stand
up to this president for doing what is
fully within his legal authority and by
the way backing down the mullahs it was
so bad it was so mean why isn't everyone
on board here's Chris Cuomo human block
of wood that's what is in the
Constitution my argument I can't believe
it wasn't unanimous and no this is not
about the GOP just choosing Trump over
the truth there's some of that but
Democrats have been anxious to give war
power to presidents as well this has
been going on for a long time and it's
gotten worse and it is the worst example
of congressional cowardice shame on you
and every Trumper and never Trump er who
voted against this unbelievable truly
this is where you're drawing the line
and what is clearly a decent kill a
correct kill killing a tear
this is where you drumlin this is where
look we gotta we gotta seize back that
congressional war-making power brock
obama conducted a four I remember arrows
there okay don't gas like me Libya was a
thing that happened it ended with the
murder of our ambassador in Benghazi it
ended with the illegitimate government
of Libya trying to govern from offshore
in an oil tanker IRA I was there it's
amazing if you ask the American people
where we ever at war in Libya it's only
been like six years for eight years
everybody like what who know what Barack
Obama was the most peaceful president
who ever was and Iran was our friend
unbelievable last word from the media
goes of course to our friends chris
matthews gotta say say so last night
he's very mad and Joaquin Castro to talk
about this head-on some other lady I
don't recognize and come on in here sit
on rubble come here they show web set
about selling money's death say money
means very popular man selling money let
me tell you about selling money how
popular was wet so bad idea tell them I
was such a popular guy so popular
probably held concerts with like
millions of screaming women who are
fainting in the aisles go chris matthews
go you know as some people die weed you
know you don't know what the impacts
gonna be when Princess Diana died for
example there was a huge emotional
outpouring these kinds of Elvis Presley
in our culture it turns out that this
generally killed was a beloved hero of
the Iranian people to the point would
look at the people who got pictures up
now these enormous crowds coming out
there's no American emotion in this case
but there's a hell of a lot of emotion
on the other side should our leaders
know what they're doing when they kill
somebody think Elvis like Princess Diana
man it's like a beautiful glamorous
woman he died in a car crash except for
like an Iranian terrorists murdered
hundreds of people but exactly the same
otherwise he's like Elvis and we thought
he was a devil in disguise nothing but a
hound dog he was actually a pocketful of
rainbows I just wanted my teddy bear but
now he's just our hunk of burning of I'm
feeling a visit to the Heartbreak Hotel
silly money always on my mind I'm
feeling all shook up Chris Matthews ever
let me say then you wonder why America
is like when Trump rips on the media
yeah okay fine fine I never I'm not an
enemy of the people kind of guy I've
never liked that commentary from
president from I don't think that the
members of the media are enemies of the
people but I think that no
cases they're enemies of the truth and
enemies of decency decency and enemies
of morality and when you are parroting
Democratic narratives because your nose
is so far up Barack Obama's ask that
it's coming out his mouth I think at
that point you've lost a lot of
credibility haven't you
okay president Trump in a rally last
night he responded to all of this and
what he said basically correct he says
it's a good thing for Iran nobody was
hurt because if somebody had gotten hurt
this is action before the rally is the
White House
he says if somebody gotten hurt then
this story would've been very different
which is why by the way is a mess I
interviewed secretary Pompeo last night
on the radio show in secretary Pompeyo I
asked him directly whether the Iranian
government had issued pre warnings to
the Iraqi government to get everybody
out of the way and he says he kind of
hesitated and then he said well I'll go
with what the Defense Secretary has said
which is that they were aiming to kill
people okay well with all due respect to
members of the administration they're
saying what they have to say because if
you wish to ratchet down tensions with
the Iranians you let them save face by
saying yeah they aimed at us but they
just miss they were just really bad at
it but there have been multiple reports
these are reports that I tend to believe
that the Iranians called up the Iraqis
they said we're gonna fire a few
missiles into your territory you're
gonna let it go and then we'll all go
home happy here's Donald Trump saying
fortunately for them nobody was hurt if
somebody had been hurt then they would
be in a world of hurt if you look at
what happened with Ukraine that's a hoax
well this is a hoax to Iran went in and
they hit us with missiles shouldn't have
done that but they hit us fortunately
for them nobody was hurt nobody was
killed
nothing happened they landed very little
damage even to the base they landed okay
and this is correct
this is correct so president Trump meant
in a rally last night at which he got a
little more fired up and he said you
know all you miners in the media and it
was amazing so there's a congressperson
and well Senator Chris Murphy from
Connecticut and he was tweeting out the
day that the US Embassy was burning in
Baghdad that this was just proof that
Trump was weak okay then Trump kills
Soleimani and Chris Murphy turns around
he's like I can't believe that he would
be so mean and so terrible Trump is like
okay you guys let Benghazi happen not
only did you let Benghazi happen you
then lied about it to the American
people for months on end and then
members of the media would mock anybody
who had questions about the lying by the
Obama administration and whether they
had taken proper precautions in the
first place don't you remember all of
those Twitter memes where people would
use the letters Benghazi and they would
tweet them vertically with silly words
in the middle because it was all a myth
why would we possibly be worried about
Benghazi and then the minute that the
embassy was burning him back that it was
like oh this is Trump's Benghazi here
was from saying now it wasn't my
Benghazi because the difference is I'm
not a pansy he ordered the violent
assault on the American Embassy in
Baghdad and you saw this was the anti
Benghazi we got there very quickly we
got there very quickly this is the exact
opposite we did it exactly the opposite
of Benghazi where they got there so late
all they saw when they got there days
later were burning embers from days
before ok President Trump is correct
about this and then President Trump goes
after Bernie Sanders and Nancy Pelosi
both of whom have been suggesting that
Trump is the aggressor in the region and
he's like you know you guys are whining
an awful lot for you could just say
thank you for me taking out Soleimani
and us not going to war you could just
do that but here's the guy who
slaughtered and butchered civilians all
over an and military whoever was in his
way and we have birdie and Nancy Pelosi
we have them all they're all trying to
say how dare you take him out that way
you should get permission from Congress
you should come in and tell us what you
want to do
you should come in and tell us so that
we can call up the fake news that's back
there and we can Lika okay so a lot of
people are very upset with President
Trump for suggesting that people like
Pelosi or Bernie would leak it and
listen do I think that the Democrats
were going to get on the horn and then
immediately leak the stuff no I don't is
there precedent for the president if for
Democrats leaking national security
information of other nations that
prevents attacks on Iran
absolutely there were several examples
of the Obama administration leaking to
the New York Times in the Washington
Post that Israel was working in
combination with countries like
Kazakhstan and Saudi Arabia
in order to use their airspace in case
they would actually have to hit the
Iranian nuclear facilities so well I
don't think that the gang of eight was
then gonna go and talk to the New York
Times or The Washington Post if he's
gonna hit Soleimani I can't help but
think that there is a then it's at the
back of my mind that says that was in
fact a a very very slight possibility
President Trump then gives the real
excuse which is listen when Soleimani
comes up and this happens like an hour
out I don't have time to call up all of
the Democrats and be like what do you
think I should do about selling money so
they want me so you know these are
split-second decisions you have to make
a decision so they don't want me to make
that decision they want me to call up
maybe go over there let me go over to
conquer so come on over to the White
House let's talk about it when can you
make it well I won't be able to make it
today sir how about
let's say it a couple of days oh come on
over now we got a call
we heard where he was we knew the way he
was getting there and we had to make a
decision we didn't have time to call up
Nancy who is not operating with a full
deck yeah and here's the bottom line
here's the bottom line take away the
Democrats right now are defending that
they're defending the Iranian regime
against the President of the United
States taking out their top terrorists
that is in effect what they are doing
because we already know they're still
operating from this ridiculous position
they had four days ago when World War
three was imminent it didn't happen it
wasn't close to happening and yet
they're so operating from that position
and so they're just gonna keep lying
about it and the American people are
gonna have to make a decision do you
want to president who is going to back
Iran off its marks words you want a
president who's gonna sign them checks
those are your two choices because the
Democrats have made very clear what
their choice should be I mean the key
Democrat here would be in the end Ilhan
Omar who was explaining yesterday that
sanctions on Iran are an act of war but
sanctions against Israel are very good
this is this lady sits on the Foreign
Affairs Committee and was praised by
Nancy Pelosi the BDS movement that is
driven by the people the sanctions on
Iran are sanctions that are being placed
to create maximum pressure by a
government that's very different okay
except for the sanctions in BDS s/s
sanctions those would be governmental
sanctions institutional sanctions being
pressed for by members like Ilhan Omar
she doesn't care about the distinction
between popular movements and the end
guy you think she'd be sad if the United
States played sanctions on Israel
tomorrow you really think that she'd be
like oh the poor Jews or it should be
like all the truth that's not a lady
like Jews very much okay but she
definitely wants to protect Iran against
the sanctions okay time for a quick
thing that I like and then a quick thing
that I hate so things that I like first
of all any video of Elizabeth Warren
dancing is a good video
what is it even funnier video is
Elizabeth Warren dancing then cory
booker defending it so elizabeth warren
is legitimately the worst dancer on
planet earth and i speak as somebody who
was an awful dancer i have a lot of
authority when i say i know bad dancing
when i see it cuz i own a mirror
elizabeth warren puts me to shame
oh my goodness uh uh it's so awkward you
can see everybody awkwardly grandmas
dancing again there's there's the the
crazy lady from the HOA wearing her
black jumpsuit and her and her latest
blue sweater and she just won't stop the
dancing you can't you can't stop won't
stop and then you got Joaquin Castro
standing next to her awkwardly clapping
and she won't stop dancing everybody
like stop dancing so Cory Booker from
there why are you making fun for dancing
why why putting my angry eyes why why
why are you stopping the dancing can't
stop the beat can't stop it by what Cory
I just want to note Cory Booker needs to
stop sending me creepy notes so Cory
Booker his campaign keeps sending over
very odd messages very odd messages so
he sent one out like two days ago they
said I'm asking you to dinner Ben first
of all I don't know it was what was
Rosario would think Cory I mean really I
think it's awkward and then he sends up
a follow-up from one of his campaign
people saying did you see Cory's note
about dinner Ben stops talking dude it's
creepy nobody wants you as a candidate
and no I'm not interested in dinner with
Cory Booker anyway he tweets out
Elizabeth Warren raise your hand if you
know why people are trolling Elizabeth's
dance moves and not my dad jokes because
your dad jokes are not nearly as funny
as Elizabeth dance moves that's why
because dad jokes are not as funny as
people dancing awkwardly but it's it's
got to be sexism is it I love that Cory
Booker is still doing me I'm the only
black person left in the race vote for
me I like women I like women like
Elizabeth Warren I'm not a sexist I'd
never make fun of a woman dancing as
though she's been hit with some sort of
galvanizing Frog electricity and
spasming now I would how dare you make
fun of this incredible dancer how dare
you make fun of a woman going how dare
you I can't believe it I can't
angry eyes out okay so there is Cory
Booker I do enjoy that yeah okay now for
this is a thing that I both like and
hate so what will count that is a thing
that I like what I hate is the
underlying the underlying reality what I
like is this documentary so this
document is one of the best
documentaries I have ever seen in my
life it is available in Amazon Prime it
is called one-child nation and it is a
deep look inside China's evil policy
from the 1970
to 2015 that mandated that Chinese
couples only have one baby this resulted
in something like 350 million forced
abortions inside the country of China it
resulted in families abandoning their
female children to death
Spartan fashion like literally taking if
they would have a baby the baby be fully
born just full-scale infanticide taking
the babies throwing them in garbage pits
taking the babies taking them to the
market leaving them there and then
letting them die the the person who
created this documentary had direct
relatives she had an aunt on one side
and an uncle on the other side her uncle
actually abandoned a female child at the
market the child died two days later of
exposure and lack of nutrition because
not a single person in the village would
take the female child because of the
one-child policy in China and what's
amazing about that I commenced rain what
remains true is that by polling data if
it were to be taken these policies
remain pretty popular in China why
because it turns out that human beings
are incredibly malleable when it comes
to their morality and when people are
informed through propaganda for decades
on end that infanticide is just a
necessary part of heightening the
collective people will go along even
with that it's why you see similar polls
in Russia
talking about the popularity of Stalin
who's only responsible for the deaths of
20 million minimum members of the USSR
population so the documentary is
disturbing also if you are a a
pro-choice person if you are a
pro-abortion person this is the only
documentary I've ever seen where people
will actually show what fetuses look
like because according to the the
leftist Western Way of morality abortion
is only bad if it's forced but if it's
voluntary it's okay and no point does
the left actually come face to face with
what it is that they are aborting in
this documentary there are actual videos
of babies fetuses that were recovered
from dump sites there's an artist in
China who recovered these these babies
these living human beings were murdered
and and preserve them and formaldehydes
that you could show people what these
babies look like and these are not
embryos right these are not these are
not zygotes these are fully formed seven
month old 8 month old nine month old
babies china used to post messages on
the wall in china up to like three years
ago four years ago they post messages on
the wall saying better to abort better
never get pregnant than to have a second
child
hey the
of collectivism cannot be overstated it
is a full-scale evil and when people
pretend that the Chinese regime is
somehow a lot more benign than the USSR
absolutely untrue remains untrue to this
day here's the trailer from the
documentary it's it's disturbing it's
heartbreaking and it's a reminder that
you are so lucky to live in the West and
most of all your children are so lucky
to live in the West and you have the
same duty to protect life in a free
country that you would in a non free
country I was born in China in 1985 a
time when China's population crisis was
making headlines around the world in an
effort to protect its people from
starvation China has enacted a policy
limiting families to just one child if
you have a second child you violate the
law I never thought much about what the
policy meant for me or anyone until I
learned that I was going to be a mom
none of my family questioned the policy
or how it was implemented
[Music]
this documentary has effectively been
banned in China they're not covering the
fact that it was shortlisted for the
Oscar there's no question it should win
the best Oscar for document for
documentaries I would be surprised if it
does simply because it is incredibly
pro-life and it has to be pro-life
because the Chinese government was
anti-life and remains hands high life
the the evils of collectivism the the
evils that human beings will will allow
in the name of collectivism truly truly
disturbing you should watch it you
should get everybody you know to watch
it it's it's a phenomenal documentary
again this stuff was happening in our
lifetimes until four years ago and the
the Chinese government is not our friend
the Chinese government is not a friend
of freedom it is not a friend to
development the Chinese government is a
horrible horrific tyrannical fascist
regime okay time for a quick let's end
the week on a bit of a higher note so
quick Bible talk very quick Bible talk
so this week's par show in in the Jewish
religion as I explained every few weeks
I've been doing this I should have been
more consistent about it every few weeks
we will talk about a portion of the
Bible that the Jews read every week so
the Jews have the cycle over the course
of the entire year the Jews read the
entire Bible so this week's parsha is
the is the very end of the book of
Genesis in Hebrew it's called by a--they
and it is the very end of the book of
Genesis when Jacob blesses his kids and
it's sort of fascinating because when
Jacob blesses his kids if you were gonna
bless your kids you would think first
and foremost what advice would I give
them what would I tell them that I think
they should know in order to succeed in
life right what are the things that I
would impart to my kids that give them
the best shot at success that's not what
Jacob does if you read the blessings
what Jacob does is he does bless them
with specific blessings but he begins by
describing each of the kids and he
doesn't describe them in glowing terms
right he talks about Simon and Levi he
talks about Shimon and Lavy and he
talked about how vindictive they are and
how likely they are to be angry he talks
about how Ephraim and nasha Ephraim and
Manasseh the kids of Joseph he talked
about how the younger will be greater
than the older right he he I mean this
is harsh stuff it's a really weird way
to bless her kids right if you if you
look at all of the blessings he he
describes everything in very specific
fashion to all of his kids
and why does he do that why does he do
that the answer is I think a real
rejection of one way that people in the
United States think about the world like
take take this for example
right he talks about ephraim and
manasseh and he brings them into the
family when he sees his grandkids and he
makes them equivalent to his sons and
then he suggests that Manasseh will be
greater than if Ryan and and all the
rest it really is sort of he crosses his
hands in order to bless one with his
right hand as opposed to his left hand
so why does he do it why does he do all
this in the West we have this perception
which is people are born with unequal
qualities and that of course is true
people are born with unequal qualities
some people are smarter some people are
dumber some people are taller some
people are like me some people can dunk
some people can't even hit a 10-foot
jump shot right the fact is that we all
have different qualities and the cause
that has unified so many people across
the world for a lot of time is to
rectify these cosmic imbalances what tom
is so we'll called the quest for cosmic
justice trying to suggest that with the
heavy hand of collectivism with the
heavy hand of government we can
re-establish a baseline equality not of
rights not that we all have equal access
to use our rights but a but a baseline
level of equality among humans and what
this means is that if there is any
disparate outcome for any people at all
some injustice has been done somewhere
and sort of rauzein morality John Rawls
famously suggested the morality was to
be placed behind the quote/unquote veil
of ignorance that we should design a
human system well you didn't know if you
were gonna be smart or whether they're
gonna be stupid whether you didn't know
why they're gonna be rich or whether
you're gonna be poor that the the best
way to design a moral system was to
operate from a morality where you didn't
know where you were going to be in the
hierarchy and therefore you construct a
morality that way well that does tend
toward a collectivism and a mentality of
collectivism because if you don't know
if you're poor or rich then you're gonna
suggest well you know it would be great
if everybody made the same then it
doesn't matter if I'm born stupid or if
I'm born smart there's one problem with
this it does not accord with human
nature and this is what Jacob is doing
Jacob is saying if you want to succeed
in life this is so true if you want to
succeed in life know your own qualities
know your own shortcomings deal with the
facts that you have these shortcomings
and that you have these qualities and
then operate in the universe on the
basis of what it is that you are capable
of doing and what you are not capable of
doing and don't try to invade the rights
of people who may have more in one area
or less in a different area
instead recognize that one of the
beauties of human existence is the
diversity between all of these various
categories and one of the things that
the free market does through comparative
advantage beautifully is it enacts the
ability for people who have variant
qualities to provide to each other or
there's one of the beautiful things
about comparative advantage that people
don't tend to understand if you are
great let's say you're very high IQ and
you're great at a lot of things right
you could be a great plumber you could
be a great writer you could be a great
business person
well what comparative advantage says is
sure you could probably be a better
plumber than the guy who's slightly
lower IQ but is that the best use of
your time rather you should specialize
in the thing that you are best at and he
will specialize in the thing that he is
best at and therefore you only have to
trade a small chunk of your time for
plumbing and he can trade a large chunk
of his time for plumbing and you're both
better off a comparative advantage takes
into account the fact that human beings
are created diverse by nature or by God
depending on how you believe this is the
way to run the system because once you
start assuming that the root of all evil
is baseline natural inequality of human
beings in terms of their actual
qualities not in terms of rights in
terms of their actual qualities once you
assume that that is inherently a bad
thing and must be cured by some
overarching Authority that God did it
wrong and that the best way for us to
cure this is to construct a system that
makes up for certain deficiencies among
all human beings again we are all
created different with different
qualities that's how you end up with
China's one-child policy that's how you
end up with full-scale tyranny and the
way that you ends up with diversity is
by acknowledging that people are
different and yes that means that some
people will be more successful than
others and yes that means that some
people are going to have an easier time
in life than others but what it also
means is that if you are one of the
people who is born without people will
appreciate you for what it is that you
are capable of doing rather than seeing
you as a leech on their own efforts it
is the quality of Rights that guarantees
that we treat each other equally as
human beings in society these do I feel
like the government is just taking away
my stuff to give it to you because
they're trying to correct for something
that I can't control and you can't
control then the society basically is
divided between the people who are
living off people and the people who are
providing to those people right the
basic Marxist notion from each according
to his ability to each according to his
need is unworkable
in terms of having a friendly decent
Society it is just not workable without
enormous amounts of coercion because
what you're essentially saying is that
there's a group of people who are
leeching off another group of people but
if you recognize that in the diversity
of humankind
you know barring the people who we must
take care of people who are of course
cannot take care of themselves people
who are ill people who have mental
illness or serious deficiencies such
that they cannot contribute in an
economy if you actually want to
construct a society where we all have
respect for one another we have to
respect each other for our strengths and
yes for our shortcomings we have to
understand that we don't have an
unlimited amount of time on this planet
and that's what Jacob is saying he's
saying listen you guys want to be
successful you tribes you're all
brothers right you love each other but
I'm not gonna pretend that all of you
are equal in all of your capacities
because you're not instead I'm gonna
describe to you what you are and if you
want to be successful in life you need
to look take a hard look at who you are
as a human being and then you need to
try and correct for your own flaws and
then you need to try and maximize your
own possibilities and you need to
respect your brothers for doing the same
that's the way to bless somebody Jacob
does it right at the end of the book of
Genesis we should all take that lesson
forward into politics and into our
personal lives as well okay we'll be
back here later today with two
additional hours of content otherwise
we'll see you here on Monday for more
news and commentary i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Rebecca Dodd poets directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling technical producer Austin
Stephens associate producer Colton Haas
assistant director Pavel white house key
edited by Adam Sai events audio is mixed
by micro Meena hair and makeup is my jl
alvera production assistant Nick Sheehan
the Ben Shapiro show is a daily where
production copyright daily wire 20/20 on
the Matt Walsh show we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation
[Music]